all right the joe biden presidency has
done a complete 180. it is stunning the
degree to which the biden presidency is
turned around think back to two and a
half or so months ago
no major no major recent accomplishments
for joe biden
approval rating in trump's favorite
place in the toilet the third element of
the bathroom
not looking good for november
the re-election of joe biden a seeming
impossibility based on the direction
things were going
but then we started to put together a
bunch of different things that took
place and from further back we had of
course uh getting out of afghanistan
which was an absolutely fantastic
decision did it go perfectly no it went
about as well as it would have if trump
had done it but we're out of afghanistan
we now have joe biden's student loan
forgiveness package which is a major
deal and i believe will absolutely help
democrats in november
we had an incredible july jobs report
about a quarter million jobs were
expected
more than half a million jobs were
actually created
wages are up
inflation is down
gas prices have been steadily coming
down and significantly we've had the
packed act signed the inflation
reduction act has been signed we've got
the older infrastructure bill which
biden did
um and then on the other side look at
what's happening for the right wing the
revelations from the january 6th
committee disastrous disastrous for
trump and people around him
completely bonkers mega nominees we'll
talk about laura loomer after the break
just cartoonish nuts running herschel
walker doug mastriano all these people
roe v wade overturned something the
right has wanted for so long absolutely
horrifying
trump busted with documents at his house
and now we learned the number of
documents is in the hundreds and it's
all completely crazy and meanwhile the
republican civil war is growing wherein
donald trump is now calling for the
removal and replacement of mitch
mcconnell as the republican leader in
the senate currently the senate minority
leader probably will remain in the
minority after the november midterms
what an incredible turnaround for joe
biden and what an incredible contrast to
what's going on on the republican side
no policy ideas they haven't had policy
ideas for years remember the health care
plan that was weeks from coming out in
the summer of 2020 and then we never got
the health care plans because there is
no health care plan no policy just get
in the way of democrats that's it
uh the civil war
the absolutely brazen nature with which
they just lie in line lying tell the
same lies over and over again including
about the 2020 election there could be
no greater contrast right now but the
contrast alone wouldn't be that notable
the two month turnaround of the biden
presidency has been stunning
now
will it make a difference in november
because it looks like democrats probably
will keep the senate but lose the house
can something different happen in the
house
if democrats were able to keep the house
and senate in november
it would be historic
given what normally happens in midterms
after a new party takes the white house
incredible
let me know your thoughts and all the
clips we played in these segments will
be on our instagram if you want to check
them out search instagram for david
pakman show and also find me on
instagram at david.pacman check out some
of my pictures from the last week in
canada and i will tell some stories on
the bonus show about that as well